other people that I know or that I work
with where it's like success is I have
to finish the script I have to shoot
this short film I have to direct my
first
movie how did you define success 20
years ago well I have a confession on
that front 20 years ago like success to
me was about how am I making someone
else happy I'm a recovering people
pleaser and a perfectionist and so
success for me was oh is my boss Happ
and so that would manifest in terms of
like I'm going to be the first one to
read the script I'm going to be the
first one to have written out my my
notes I'm going to be the first one etc
etc etc because I was really conscious
of some of the deficits that I had in my
experience because I was like a late
bloomer I didn't move to Hollywood until
I was 26 years old and all of my friends
and you know people that I went to
school with had had gone to LA right
after college and so I'm like oh my God
I'm four years by behind and so I always
felt like okay the way that I'm going to
try to get ahead is by being first so
maybe that's how I define success but it
was mostly about how is someone
responding to me what does success mean
now oh I love this
question success for me right now is
really am I and this is going to maybe
sound a little bit hokey but like am I
being authentic to myself because I'm a
recovering perfectionist and people
pleaser I really have to check in with
myself to say okay is this something
that I truly want do I truly need and so
like that's the first layer and then I
guess the next layer of success for me
is um I am goal oriented and so like on
a daily or weekly or a monthly basis I
have like my list of like am I checking
off these boxes because in the big
picture on that outer outer layer is and
I don't have necessarily a lot of
control over this is that I want to have
a positive impact on people's lives I
want to be able to help people really
enjoy the processes that they're engaged
with professionally and especially
within the entertainment industry where
I feel like the processes of creating
cont content and developing content
they're sort of broken and I find it so
ironic that an industry that's built on
creativity is it it condemns people
for when there's failure but great
creative doesn't come unless there's
failure and so I really like if I had a
a big dream and like to define success
it would be to say okay let's
Embrace creative failure so that we can
continue to be able to like find stories
and and really be able to reflect what's
really happening in the world does that
make sense it does I think you know part
of your backstory and maybe it'll come
out more in the interview you've talked
about you know different points in your
life when things weren't going well and
I think it sounds like you really
Embrace being okay with that and then
trying to rise
up yes there's just so much judgment and
I'm a big believer in assessment I think
it's so important to be able to assess
like what went right so that we can
continue to you know use it as a
foundation and then also assess like
what hasn't gone right why did this fail
but to remove judgment out of it so take
the good and the bad out of the
conversation and really like look at
okay what what are like the mechanics of
something or what's like my mental
processes that may be stopping or
slowing me from being able to take a
swing and try something that's really
exciting and new and
different and it sounds like too doesn't
matter the gender people experience
failure in in in equal ways maybe in
different compartments yeah I mean
failure is just is a natural part of who
we are it's like from you know thinking
about like in your childhood I don't
even know if you remember this I don't
remember with learning how to walk but
it's like toddlers like they're called
toddlers because they're toddling along
and then they're constantly like trying
to take a step and then they fall and
they get back up again and then
somewhere along the way we've been
taught that that's not okay that it's
not okay to fail or to have a mistake or
to need to hold on to something in order
to take a couple of steps and
so yeah I don't know where I started to
go with that but just thinking about
failure in that regard or mistakes in
that regard and that it is it's like so
important to be able to say it's okay
and to be able to assess as opposed to
judge well we were going to talk about
this a little later but I know you've
said something in other interviews about
what you call the face plant moment
which I think is like a brilliant
analogy and we've all had them uh I
guess it's how graceful we get back up I
mean it's kind of like if you trip and
if you're going to a conference and you
trip in front of a room of people
Everyone's Watching how do you handle it
yeah
absolutely as you were talking I was
just thinking about when I was an
assistant at Triad which was an agency
back in the early 90s it was my first
job in Hollywood and there was an
amazing woman she was the head of
business affairs
and and she really took me and a couple
of other assistants under her wing and
we could ask her just like the stupid
questions of like what is net mean what
does gross mean what are points what is
packaging you all of that stuff and I
remember she was running down the
hallway and she always dressed so
smartly always like a really great
blouse and and a skirt and a jacket and
she was running down the hallway there
was some phone call that was really
urgent and she literally face planted
and it was and I remember like
witnessing it going oh my God and then
she got up and I and I can still see
this in my head and she she started to
cry because it was just so embarrassing
to have this literal face plant in front
of all of these people and then I was
like oh my God she's now crying in front
of all these people and I just thought
it was so vulnerable and my admiration
for her just
skyrocketed and you know and she's a
woman as well so she's being judged
differently than anybody else and and so
I think you're actually helping me
realize something in this moment as I'm
talking about it is that I think that
really planted a seed for me in terms of
really looking at face plants in a
particular way because it didn't affect
her talent and her ability her expertise
of how effective she was it was just
like it was just a face PL she just
tripped wow you know that could be
written into a script right there
because it really could set the the tone
for like the opening of a show or
something yeah and then you show that
this person's actually a Powerhouse but
you see how vulnerable they were in that
moment wow that's I felt like I was
right there when you were telling the
story
yeah wow so maybe that's where yeah that
came from because I've heard you say it
and I was like yeah yeah that's a good
anal like face plant we we've hopefully
it's not every day we but you know we've
all had them um do we all have different
definitions of success oh yeah
absolutely and
uh I think about
um
uh I'm just laughing because for me is
like success is like how many boxes of
like on my daily to-do list can I check
off and then I'm thinking
about other people that I know or that I
work with where it's like success is I
have to fit finish the script I have to
shoot the short film I have to direct my
first movie and then there are other
people outside of the entertainment
industry where it's like
successes um I just I was listening to a
podcast um
where success is walking to the
mailbox because this
person has a chronic illness and that's
just the best they can
do and and so but that's a huge thing
and and so yeah success is very
different for all of us isn't it I mean
there's public failure that we see but
there's probably also so much private
failure that we would have no
idea relationship suffering or you know
people being sabotaged yeah different
things yeah I also have to think about
success from the the lens of working in
a capitalistic Society I mean we we from
from the west and so our values are so
different than other parts of the world
and I I think that for a lot of people
at least people that I encounter or that
I've grown up with that success is
frequently defined on the professional
realm and then and then people talk
about oh success is um you know have I
raised happy healthy kids am I a good
spouse or am I a good partner but then
when I and I don't mean this to sound
judgmental it's really an observation
but then when I look at how they spend
their time and the things that they're
devoting their lives to and their
energies and even financial investments
it's on the professional realm so while
it's not necessarily oneto one of like
where you put your time is where you
know you're looking to achieve or attain
success I do think there's some type of
correlation and so I think the cost of
success
is I think there's always a cost but it
obviously it depends on on the
individual and the circumstances like
when I think about the success that I've
had in my career is really come from
like the cost of it is spending time
with my kids and with my husband which
uh which has really severely been
compromised and of course they're
important to me and they're a priority
but there's so many times and it's and
and I can even I even said to my
daughter this morning it's like I need
to go work for a couple of hours and
it's a Saturday morning and I'm I'm not
spending time with her because I'm
invested in the success of my
career well I think I was listening to a
panel or an interview with is it Sophia
amaroso from girl boss yeah fascinating
story and I realized you were executive
producer um on the Netflix show and she
basically said that it just got to a
point where it was like she was on these
panels and oh she had made the Forbes or
the 30 under 30 or whatever it was and
it was just so dizzying that she started
to ask herself do I even like like
fashion like what is all this like it
happens so fast for her yeah and our
values and our priorities change because
new experiences occur data comes in we
grow up we you know we just we grow in
different ways and and so sometimes I
think that there's a social construct
that our lives have to be static it's
like okay you want to be a writer you
want to be a director you want to be an
actress and then you just have to pick a
lane a single Lane
and stay in that and I personally like
really rebel against that it's like I
love being a producer I love being a
coach I love being a professor and I
frequently he people like but what are
you and and so when I when I get asked
that question I have to go back to my my
purpose it's like my life purpose is
helping people across their Finish Line
and I get to do that in all of these
different ways and I also get to do it
as a parent I get to do it as a spouse I
get to do it as as a friend and and so I
really I I understand like Sophia's you
know perspective in terms of yeah there
came a point in her life where this Lane
that she had chosen it just no longer
was fulfilling or it didn't resonate
with her values anymore but so
frequently we're not given permission to
change our mind and we're judged for
that